it's your birthday do you um now that
you're one year or older do you feel
uh the vice grip of time
grabbing you by the neck and squeezing
and squeezing until there's no life left
i didn't until you said that hey there
i'm raine wilson and i'm reza aslan and
together we've got a brand new podcast
metaphysical milkshake that's right we
ask all of life's big questions and
sometimes even answer them and we're not
afraid to get weird along the way and
speaking of weird we're out here on the
street asking just random strangers
what's their life's big question nothing
weird about that no that's totally
normal pandemic so life's big questions
you guys have any what is the meaning of
all this why are we here what am i gonna
do
with your life yeah
is he gonna
give me a baby oh yeah wow which
religion to choose what are you looking
for in a religion for it to not feel
cult-like not too too many rules like
what's the point of
doing anything in a way because we were
saying like we're like speckles of dust
practically yeah i'm kind of depressed
now yeah you've gotten me really but
this is kind of an existential despair
you're experiencing do you believe in
soul mates i don't know that's a great
question this is a good question this is
gonna this is gonna turn out bad i mean
i can't picture anybody else and also
you know that's final answer enough
sticking to it
how can i make everyone in my life happy
and loved and i always struggle with
that because you can only do so much for
so many people while also fueling what
you need no rules
yeah not too many religion without rules
chanting chanting yes or no guess if
it's not forced optional don't force me
to chant god yes or no or whatever god
probably so i feel like the fastest
road to unhappiness
is making everyone else happy finding
the balance but at the same time making
other people happy can be one of the
deepest most satisfying kinds of
happiness it's a conundrum we've got god
we've got community chanting but not
forced
drugs are okay though in this religion
drugs are fine i do think there is um
such thing as a soulmate but i do think
people have multiple soul mates the
algorithms of the universe said that we
were meant to be
on
tinder going along with milkshake
metaphor we've got a bunch of life's big
questions right here in this blender if
you had
to switch religions which would you
choose well no that isn't exactly same
question
that is literally definitely a message
when in life is a human being's prime
right now but when is now for you
well i'm 32.
so it's uh i'm 28.
no i just did one of the takes
is wealth evil
everyone thinks the bible says money is
the root of all evil that's not what the
bible says the bible says
the love of money is the root of all
evil ah is anyone better than keanu
reeve
no no is being famous good for your
health well
[Music]
oh can we officiate your wedding oh my
god right now i'm ordained ordained the
minister he could get you guys married
right now
let's do this this is your car right
this is this is my car
oh no oh sometimes rain steals cars this
was all just to get your car that's all
this was this can't happen
this officially can't happen if you've
learned anything today
never leave your car
running while asking life's biggest
questions my
life's big
big questions thank you so much chris
take care these are an adorable couple
they're doing really good they'll never
make it i i don't i don't think they'll
last
that wasn't so bad yeah let's call it a
day extra ones here well a lot of extra
life's questions well let's try and
answer some of these are women better
than men in so many ways absolutely so
in so many ways hey everyone if you
liked that video please subscribe to the
metaphysical milkshake youtube channel
smash the button wherever it is
tibetan buddhism
tibetan buddhism you can really get into
some sex stuff oh the tantrums the
tantric stuff i'm talking about like
buddhism oh no no i thought that was all
it was